monsieur georges pompidou vous voici
face à la bataille décisive de
l'élection présidentielle vous allez
affronter ce second tour avec l'appui de
10 millions de français et de françaises
qui vous ont fait confiance au premier
tout en les remerciant dimanche soir ses
électeurs et électrices
vous avez dit que près d'un français sur
deux vous avez apporté sa voix
le matin ils voient ce le plus difficile
à faire il va vous falloir convaincre
plus d'un français sur deux alors
qu'allez vous leur dire à ces français
là pendant cette bataille du second tour
de la présidentielle
eh bien écoutez madame au 1er tour vous
avez les candidats sont nombreux et
automatiquement les voix se disperse
chacun suivant un petit peu ses
affinités politiques ou même son goût
pour telle ou telle personnalité au
second tour c'est un choix un choix
entre deux candidats
et cette fois ci me semble que le choix
est particulièrement clair puisque je
pars avec une avance de voix
considérable et que d'ailleurs les
français dans leur ensemble me
paraissent avoir marqué leur volonté
d'aller vers l'avenir et non pas de
retourner vers le passé alors le
problème pour moi c'est de les
convaincre que le chef de l'état doit
avoir une majorité massive afin de
bénéficier d'une autorité suffisante
autorités à l'extérieur pour représenter
la france et les intérêts des français
autorités à l'intérieur pour faire face
aux difficultés de tous ordres qui sont
le lot de tous les gouvernements
vous avez parlé d'une autorité massive
mais vous savez qu'un effet
caractéristique est majorité passionnel
majorité oui d'une majorité massive et
vous savez bien que 1 des faits
exceptionnels de ce second tour
c'est l'abstention que le parti
communiste recommande aux électeurs qui
ont voté pour monsieur jacques duclos au
21 % d'électeurs qui ont voté pour
monsieur jacques duclos est ce que vous
ne craignez pas que ces abstentionnistes
politique s'ajoutant aux
ce temps cialiste traditionnels ne
diminue votre autorité si vous étiez élu
eh bien je crois justement je crois
justement que c'est le devoir d'abord de
tous les électeurs qui ne sont pas
communiste de ne pas s' de d'éviter à
tout prix de s'abstenir car s'abstenir
pour eux cette fois ci ça sera mêlé
leurs voix à ceux du parti communiste et
surtout je dirais permettre au parti
communiste de se les attribuer alors
qu'elle ne le serait point du tout je
crois d'ailleurs aussi que beaucoup
d'électeurs qui votent qu'on vous pu
voter pour monsieur jacques duclos parce
que son programme les séduisait beaucoup
de ses électeurs se rendront compte de
la nécessité que qui s'impose à un
citoyen quel qu'il soit de faire son
devoir est de choisir et je ne vois
vraiment pas pourquoi dans ce choix
beaucoup de ces milieux l'ouvrier ou
petits paysans ou autres le choisirait
parce que je représente
c'est à dire naturellement le progrès
économique et le progrès social aussi
bien que la dignité de tous les français
justement parmi vos objectifs vous avez
le dialogue
or il est un secteur qui intéresse tous
les français et les françaises c'est
bien le dialogue social
comment envisagez vous de le louer ce
dialogue social
égoutter il ne s'agit pas de le louer il
s'agit me semble-t-il plutôt de lui
permet de s'exercer de lui permet de
s'exercer partout et de le favoriser
il y ait un dialogue qui existe
d'ailleurs entre l'état et telle ou
telle catégorie sociale
c'est le cas par exemple de l'état avec
tous ses employés et dieu sait qu'ils
sont nombreux
c'est aussi le cas de l'état lorsqu'il à
débattre des intérêts des agriculteurs
ou des commerçants par rapport à la
réglementation d'état par rapport à la
fiscalité par rapport à l'administration
mais ce à quoi je pensais surtout c'est
à favoriser le dialogue entre le
patronat et les salariés dans tout ce
qui est industries et en particulier de
les inciter à se rencontrer à 10
lutter véritablement des problèmes et à
montrer qu'ils sont les uns et les
autres
capable d'assumer leurs propres
responsabilités et par là même capable
finalement de s'entendre car les
intérêts sont communs et la prospérité
de l'entreprise bénéficie et doit
bénéficier à tout le monde c'est ce que
j'ai citées par exemple quand j'ai parlé
d'ouvrir des négociations sur le passage
du salaire horaire au salaire mensuel
jeu reviendra d'ailleurs sur ces
questions dans un autre entretien
télévisé consacré davantage aux
problèmes économiques et sociaux
justement de quelle autre problème allez
vous parler pendant cette campagne dans
cette campagne je voudrais m'élever au
dessus des partis au dessus des
querelles de personnes et je voudrais
essayer de définir les grands thèmes qui
sont ceux de la politique de la france
qu'ils s'agissent de politique
extérieure qu'ils agissent de politique
intérieure et il va de soi que dans les
circonstances actuelles
j'attache une priorité aux problèmes
économiques et sociaux
vous allez faire intervenir pour vous
interroger à la télévision des hommes
politiques qui appartiennent à
différentes tendances qui représente en
réalité la famille qui soutient votre
candidature
c'est ce que vous appelez la politique
d'ouverture
cette politique d'ouverture vous voulez
la pratique et sans reniement ni
abaissement certains de vos adversaires
vous savez disent pourtant que vous
preniez votre action politique passée
qu'est ce que vous ressentez quand vous
entendez cet argument goûter le rhône et
dans une campagne électorale soumis à
tant de critiques qu'on finit par être
un tout petit peu indifférent il
n'allait pas moins vrai que cette
critique l'âme touche parce que je la
trouve particulièrement injuste
lille est pas question de me renier par
conséquent j'entends bien maintenir
l'essentiel de ce qui a été la politique
j'ai pu mener parlant si longtemps aux
côtés du général de gaulle qu'il
s'agisse des institutions et donc de la
stabilité gouvernementale qui permet
l'efficacité qu'il s'agisse de la
politique étrangère et de biens
d'autres domaines par contre et vous
avez raison de le dire madame
par contre je veux pratiquer une
politique d'ouverture associés à
l'action gouvernementale
tous ceux qui acceptent ces principes
généraux et qui apportent des idées
différentes des nuances dans les idées
un enrichissement par la variété de même
que je voudrais que dans les rapports
entre le gouvernement et le parlement
il y est peut-être un peu plus de
liberté un peu plus de confiance mais
tout cela c'est plus une affaire de
moeurs est d'habitude qu'une affaire de
programme proprement dit vous aviez dit
que pendant que vous étiez au
gouvernement vous aviez appris beaucoup
de choses mais qu'après pendant la
période qui a suivi quand vous n'étiez
plus premier ministre l'a également vous
aviez tirer des enseignements
puis je vous demander lesquels vous
savez d'abord pendant six ans le
gouvernement change beaucoup on apprend
beaucoup et je me suis certainement
former progressivement
quant à ces dix mois de réflexion j'ai
en effet souligné l'importance qu'ils
avaient pour moi dans mon expérience
parce que en revenant un citoyen comme
les autres même si on a un rôle
politique en mars on est beaucoup plus
conscients de ce qu'est la vie des gens
de ce que sont leurs difficultés
quotidiennes leurs problèmes personnels
et réels et c'est ça qui m'a beaucoup
frappé à quel point vu de l'extérieur
l'action de l'état du gouvernement de
l'administration peut sembler souvent
oppressive incompréhensibles aux simples
citoyens et l'ayant senti eh bien je
voudrais que l'action du gouvernement
tel que je pourrai l'animé
cette action soit différente soit plus
humaines plus accessible plus
compréhensive vous savez qu'on parle
beaucoup en ce moment d'un affrontement
entre le gaullisme et le communisme en
affrontement qu'il faut éviter
en créant ce qu'on appelle aussi une
force d'appoint le sang en maintenant
une force d'appoint que penser de cette
analyse politique eh bien madame gens
pensent de choses ou bien c'est une
conception purement parlementaire on
imagine qu'il ya une gauche qui a une
droite et puis
quelqu'un au milieu qui en poussant
penchait tantôt à gauche tantôt à droite
pourra en fin de compte diriger le tout
c'est le système des groupes charnières
c'est un système qui nous a conduits à
la décadence et à l'incapacité voilà je
suis clair vous voyez mais c'est la
vérité
il ya une autre conception aussi
différentes
alors c'est de croire que la politique
est un jeu une espèce de combat de boxe
où il ya deux groupes qui échanger coups
de poing et alors on dit il serait utile
qui au milieu un édredon pour amortir
les coûts moi j'ai une autre conception
je crois que la politique ça consiste à
essayer de guider le pays vers des
objectifs vers des réalisations vers des
progrès et que dans ce cas là eh bien il
ya une majorité qui gouverne que
l'opposition petit participé d'ailleurs
de façon constructive et qu'en tout cas
je n'y vois pas le rôle de l'édredon
vous savez qu'il y à un slogan qu'on a
beaucoup utilisé contre le gaullisme en
particulier contre le général de gaulle
et que l'on commence à reprendre contre
vous même c'est le slogan du pouvoir
personnel
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous du
pouvoir personnel le général de gaulle
madame vous l'avez connu était une
personnalité d'une telle ampleur que
tout ce qui se faisait lui étaient
attribués et très souvent on parlait de
ses diktats de ses ordres de ces
instructions formelles
alors que les choses s'étaient passées
dans la réalité de façon tout à fait
différent néanmoins je le répète avec
une personnalité de cette importance à
la taille de l'état
tout le monde a tendance apparaît
pouvoir personnel sur ce point j'offre
malgré tout quelques garanties
je ne pense pas que l'on puisse
prétendre que ma personnalité suffira à
imposer à tout le monde une politique
dont personne le voudrait
par contre pas contre permettez moi de
vous dire que si je ne suis pas du tout
pour le pouvoir personnel je ne suis pas
non plus du tout pour le pouvoir
un personnel c'est-à-dire pour un
système où on ne sait jamais qui
responsable et où finalement tout
contrôle
que ce soit le contrôle parlementaire où
le contrôle populaire n'a plus aucun
sens ni plus aucune portée parce que
chacun répète ce n'est pas de ma faute
ce n'est pas de ma faute
il faut qu'ils aient les responsables à
tous les échelons
chacun à sa place parlement gouvernement
chef de l'état et soyez certains que
j'assumerai
si je suis chef de l'état ou qu'en tout
cas je tâcherai d'assumer mes
responsabilités pleinement et sans
aucunement tendre vers le pouvoir
personnel ni vers la dictature
puisque nous sommes dans les critiques
on a dit aussi qu'un un clan gaulliste
s'était approprié la république
que faut-il entendre par là voilà qui
nous obligerait à une longue discussion
sur le passé est ce que le clan
gaulliste s'est approprié la république
est ce que les autres nous ont quittés
nous ont laissés seuls mener cette
république est ce que l'ont pas vu tout
le temps se refaire le cartel des noms
et cet esprit de revanche qui est si
fâcheux et dont il faut sortir il faut
que les français seraient concilier
s'unissent au lieu d'être coupée en deux
blocs dont chacun peuvent dans le bloc
opposants espèrent sans cesse chasser
l'autre et prendre sa place je voudrais
désormais que les institutions soit
admise
je voudrais désormais que chacun accepte
dans son for intérieur de jouer le jeu
réel la vème république et dès lors
chacun peut participer
que ce soit dans la majorité que ce soit
même dans l'opposition mais une
opposition constructive
vous venez nous le rappeler vous n'êtes
pas général de gaulle êtes un homme
différent
alors si vous êtes élu président de la
république quel genre de président serez
vous quel sera votre style le général de
gaulle s'imposait comme nous lisions
tout à l'heure beaucoup parlent simple
coefficient personnel
le nouveau président aura besoin de
s'appuyer sur d'autres réalités pour
faire de la france un pays respecté
pays prospère il faudra qui s'appuie sur
une réalité économique
c'est à dire que la france devienne un
grand pays industriel et agricole
il fera qui s'appuie sur une réalité
sociale c'est à dire que les rapports
entre les hommes entre les groupes
sociaux soient transformés améliorer
humanisé et que chacun se sente
véritablement membres d'une même
communauté
il faudra qu'ils sautent qu'il s'appuie
également sur une réalité politique
c'est à lire cette pauline cette large
ouverture le plus grand nombre possible
d'hommes au gouvernement au parlement et
dans le pays et je pense au scrutin du
dimanche 15 juin pour le reste je
voudrais surtout être un président le
plus près possible des hommes et le plus
semblable si je puis dire à tous les
français vous à b dans l'antiquité
romaine
il y avait un usage quand un général un
homme d'état veut remporter un grand
succès on lui donnait la cérémonie du
triomphe c'est à dire qu'on le mettait
sur un char y montait au capitole au
milieu d'honneur exceptionnel et puis il
y avait quelqu'un à côté de lui qui lui
disait sans cesse à l'oreille rappelle
toi que tu n'es qu'un homme eh bien je
voudrais pour ma part comme président de
la république si je le suis rappeler
sans cesse que je ne suis qu'un français
parmi les français et par là même que je
suis calme donc capable de les
comprendre et de comprendre leurs
problèmes et leurs soucis
c'est ça au fond qui sera ma
préoccupation permanente